I have good news and bad news to start with
today, and therefore same depending on your
perspective.
Donald Trump last night gave what is likely
to be his last rally ever as president of
the United States.
If you like the Trump craziness, it's coming
to an end.
If you dislike it, it's coming to an end.
So it's good or bad, depending on your perspective.
It was bizarre.
It was deranged.
It was also really boring.
And it took place in Georgia.
The point of the rally supposedly was to support
the two Republican senators running in today's
elections, Kelly Lefler and David Perdue.
But down to every detail, the entire event
was a farce.
David Perdue couldn't even be at the rally
because he's in coronavirus quarantine.
Of the nearly 90 minutes that Donald Trump
ranted, almost none of it was about the Senate
candidates.
It was mostly about Trump, much of it telling
lie after lie.
It is not an exaggeration to say Donald Trump
told hundreds of lies during yesterday's rally,
insisting he won at one point simply citing
supposed county level vote count numbers from
election night.
The crowd completely silent for long stretches
of the rally and down to the last element.
I mean, even Trump's face more orange than
we've ever seen it.
Despite his pale hands, every detail could
not have been more absurd and as I like to
say, indistinguishable from satire.
So let's get right into it.
Here is Donald Trump within seconds opening
up the rally by lying about the results in
Georgia.
I want to thank you very much.
Hello, George.
By the way, there's no way we lost Georgia.
This no rig.
That was a rigged election.
So we're still fighting it.
And you'll see what's going to happen.
We'll talk about it.
And and this was the theme.
Trump moments later saying, if Democrats take
the White House and then realizing, hold on
a second.
No, no, no, they're not taking it.
We won.
If the liberal Democrats take the Senate to
the White House and they're not taking this
White House, we're going to fight like hell.
I'll tell you right now.
And the theme was that the crowd really didn't
seem to care very much about Lefler and Purdue,
they seemed to just be there for Trump.
But even Trump got too boring for them for
long stretches.
And they tuned out, which will get to Donald
Trump, then alluding to once again hoping
that Mike Pence can steal the election for
him tomorrow.
And I hope Mike Pence comes through for us.
I have to tell you, I hope that our great
vice president, our great vice president comes
through for us.
He's a great guy because if he doesn't come
through, I won't like him quite as much.
So this is wild for two reasons.
First, that Donald Trump is publicly pressuring
the vice president to steal the election.
And second, that Donald Trump seems to believe
that Mike Pence can steal the election.
Pence's role in Washington, D.C. tomorrow,
as we talked about yesterday, is really perfunctory.
And we're all going to see that tomorrow.
So I won't get get ahead of myself.
Here is an example of Donald Trump ranting
about things nobody in the crowd seemed to
understand.
And the crowd is silent.
At one point I wondered, did the crowd leave?
But they were they're just not making a peep.
And you've got to swarm it tomorrow.
Now, the good thing about tomorrow, it's one
stage.
So you have a lot of eyeballs watching.
It's tougher than when you have 50 states
and they do it to various various states.
I never said they like it.
I was leading in Pennsylvania by hundreds
of thousands of votes.
All of a sudden I was tired.
I said, what happened?
They'll make Washington, D.C. and other liberal
places the 50 first, 50 second, 50 third states
of the union, guaranteeing you can almost
hear the room tone louder than you can hear
the crowd.
It's really wild how dead silent Trump was
able to get this crowd to be.
Trump then defiantly clarifying he does not
concede, even though he did lose two months
ago.
After all, nothing and no one will be able
to stop them.
These Senate seats are truly the last line
of defense.
Now, I must preface that by saying because
they'll say he just conceded.
No, no, I don't think so.
That got the crowd awake, Trump not conceding
that's the one thing he should be doing and
mentioning that is what really gets the crowd
fired up.
So then this is funny.
When Donald Trump did talk about David Perdue
and Carly Lefler, which was almost not at
all, but that was the point of the rally.
In theory, the crowd is totally bored when
Trump talks about Perdue and Lefler.
Here he is talking about David Perdue, who
it wasn't even clear whether Trump knew Perdue
wasn't there because he was quarantining.
Doesn't matter.
You'll see the camera if you're watching pan
around.
And although the lack of masks is notable,
the lack of enthusiasm is as well.
Over the last four years, David Perdue has
been one of our greatest allies and strongest
defenders in Washington.
He's a great gentleman.
And then the crowd just as bored when Trump
was talking about Carly Lefler, just barely
a cheer.
Georgia has another fantastic champion and
Senator Kelly Lefler.
Kelly is a staunch defender of our incredible
military.
I'm so proud of our military.
She supports the war and she always stands
with the heroes of law enforcement ICE.
Usually they pump up the crowd noise.
I was wondering whether they were suppressing
the crowd noise.
And that's a joke.
They weren't.
The crowd was just that silent for much of
this rally.
A deflated, empty speech, the cringe.
Yes, moment in the whole thing was probably
this moment when Donald Trump called up Republican
Senate candidate Carly Lefler to the stage
and she had an announcement to make, which
was that tomorrow she will object, object
to the counting of the electoral votes that
got the crowd interested.
They woke up for that.
Hello, Georgia.
Thank you, George.
I have an announcement, Georgia, on January
6th, I will object to the Electoral College
vote.
That's right.
Thank you.
What energy, right, I mean, just the energy
just oozing off of Kelly Lefler there, loudly
announcing she will also be making a fool
out of herself in Washington, D.C. tomorrow.
And Trump then seemed to be visibly struggling
to get to the end of his speech.
You're going to hear him sort of slurring
here, mixing up words.
The last 20 minutes were just one of the most
poorly delivered speeches that I've seen from
Trump, and that says a lot.
We've all seen what our opponents are capable
of doing.
I ran to elections.
I won both of them.
Second one, much more successful than the
first.
But we can't let this happen any longer on
election night.
We were leading by so much.
We're not going to have that tomorrow.
So then this is the part that's really nuts
for about 20 straight.
And it's Trump Red with terrible inflection
in tone, alleged voting results from various
counties.
And here he is wanting to talk about Maricopa
County, Arizona, but he's only only able to
get out the word Mayakoba.
And it doesn't even matter because everybody's
tuned out by this point anyway.
So his constituents reported that their earlier
in-person ballots may not have been correctly
processed or tabulated.
And Maricopa County officials.
Yes.
So this was the part that had the crowd completely
checked out, just droning on like this for
20 minutes.
Here's another part of it.
You could really hear a pin drop in this place.
The committee then heard additional testimony
concerning voting irregularities during the
2020 general election, including testimony
and a real time test demonstrating serious
irregularities with Dominion's voting machines.
Three events discussed at this hearing stand
out and require a forensic order of the Dominion
voting machines in Georgia to be immediately
conducted.
The one phrase that woke people back up was
Trump mentioning Dominion voting machines.
The sycophants have almost been trained in
a Pavlovian manner.
If you hear dominion that you have to react
to.
But they were really struggling to remain
even remotely engaged with Trump droning on
and on about votes and ballots.
And then during his wind up sort of crescendo,
Trump actually glitches on the word America
and he tries to cover it up by flexing his
bicep.
We have made America stronger again.
Look at that.
Trump commonly does this.
We saw this dozens and dozens of times during
his presidency when he sort of glitches out
during a word.
He'll do something physical to distract from
it.
He'll flex his arm or he'll slap the lectern
a couple of times, or he'll turn to the other
side of the audience and say, whoa, hey, how
about that?
So Trump's final rally, as expected, all about
himself.
He seemed sort of to try to go through the
motions of talking about David Perdue and
Carly Lefler, but he really couldn't do it.
And what he did do is spend a lot of time
claiming that he won in November.
We are very close to the end, very, very close.
And the next question is, what will Trump
do between tomorrow when the electoral votes
are counted and January 20th when Joe Biden
is sworn in?
Will we see him at all?
Will he tweet?
Will he go crazy tweeting?
Will he not tweet at all?
We don't know.
But you can join me tonight live on YouTube,
Twitch and Facebook for Georgia Senate results
starting somewhere in the 7:00 p.m. Eastern
hour.
And then tomorrow at 1:00 p.m. Eastern, join
me live on YouTube, Twitter and Facebook for
the counting of the electoral votes, supposedly
the last stand for the Trump.
That's tomorrow, 1:00 p.m. Eastern.
Join me tonight and join me tomorrow.